take [__] notes guys texting and your
dick pics don't work yeah at least hide
it a little bit or do it if you're
dressing it up you know what I mean put
a bow what a tie if I was you know in my
youth and dick pic sharing was the thing
like I think I would dress it up you
know what I mean I would make it more of
a of a funny thing girl yeah something
like a little Sombrero google eyes
little google eyes right I would also
give it a holster you know what I mean
with a little pistol and [__]
something is it is it well kept it's the
first thing that I would do right you
know what what are what are some areas
that needs work right it's like what's
that little pimple doing that
oh
perfect